all right
let's go
got some get guess the elo before i go
thank you heck m and burton ice
the primes appreciate it thanks guys for
all the prime subs all the subs in
general
let's do a couple okay so we've got g
g4
[Music]
okay this is really weird
okay white's like reacting to all the
threats
white's actually playing well despite
the opening
gosh
or not
no white actually played really well but
white lost on time okay so
oh i let the pawn through
okay i'm gonna say like 1500.
and white played well this could be
higher
this could be higher than i i tend to
underestimate okay let's say 1600 or no
but but honestly
but black
no it's not 900 it's higher than 900
no i don't think it's 900 i'm going to
say 1400
it's 1678 i should have gone with my
initial guess
um but still good
i i told you guys it's not 900 because
white was playing too well for it to be
900
um okay
so i'm gonna trust my gut
okay so we have a naidorf
ish knight of five bishop okay no
missing knight g7 that's a pretty big
red flag
okay white's actually playing well king
h1
okay we're blundering a piece in a very
elementary fashion
and then bla and then white had rook
takes g6 maybe
okay
this is probably around the same thing i
mean
maybe 1700
who had a bad day
maybe a 1700 who had a bad day
with bishop e7 come on missing knight
takes g7
no 1300
1300
yes 1413 good i was happy i brought it
down
okay
um
but just because you're like 1700 and
you're like i wouldn't play like this
doesn't mean it can't be a 1700.
okay knight f6
knight e5 queen c7
castle's castle so this is pretty much
modern theory h3
c5 okay c5 is pretty impressive
black is playing queen b7 nice move
queen c7
black is playing really well this game
okay black played a phenomenal game oh
my god
are you kidding me
um
the problem is white didn't play very
well so
bishop e3 is a weird move
no white was not 2 000. i'm going to say
i'm going to say 1800
i think black was
i'm going to say 1850.
i might be grossly overestimating it but
i feel like blackblade really well
2087 good yeah that was that was the
right amber hood
i was not overestimating it
okay i'm doing very well so
far but there's always the flub there's
always one i say okay g3 is already a
red flag a3
yeah this is like a thousand level
okay
obviously this is like not very advanced
players
yeah the podcast of levy is recorded it
was real okay rook is hanging yeah this
is like 800.
okay knight c5 is impressive though wow
look at the idea knight c5 you can't
take the knight because it's
pinned that's really funny and queen e7
okay blender in the night i'm going to
say like a thousand
both forks
i'm no in 1100 i'm going to say 1100
15 30 okay okay reasonable that's a
little higher than i realized that's a
little bit higher than i expected but i
could kind of see that
um that was reasonable
levy is watching me no i'm doing i'm
doing pretty well okay so we have a
king's gambit
i have a king's gambit
this is sort of main line theory g5 okay
black knows what he's doing
okay that hangs the pawn on g5
okay black does not know what he's doing
anymore
okay white is playing well bishop f8
okay but why why did the knight get to
see some okay at least he gets to trade
see they're putting together strings of
pretty decent moves so white's up in
exchange and white lost this game
probably on time
oh whoops
yeah probably white was in time pressure
so
what am i gonna say
i'm gonna say 1600 that's like my
yeah
1600 1700
1500
all right all right let me better be
watching this
how's that
all right how's that
this is like my best run so far
all right
t4 d5 e4 so we have a black mart dmr
gambit
already wins the pawn bishop b5
bishop takes d7
bishop d7 is a red flag
okay that's a fork but white takes on d7
b2
whoops blundering a rook yeah
i'm gonna say
let's say thirteen hundred
let's say thirteen hundred
[Laughter]
all right
i swear i didn't see these games
beforehand
okay um
i'm getting the hang of this game
so we have a karo khan fantasy variation
okay this is high level this is like
theory this is definitely over 2000
queen h4 queen h5
a little bit odd to go into this really
bad end game but black plays e5
be four knight c1
okay that was a mouse slip obviously
um i'm gonna say 2300
it could be even higher than that
i don't really this is a red flag to me
queen h4 queen h5 is really weird
but
over the overall they played really well
i mean both of them really
maybe even higher than 2300 i'm going to
say 25 one 20 no i'm gonna go with my
gut
let's say 2400
2214 okay should have gone with 2300 but
uh still pretty good
all right 22 14 is the actual
okay moving on so we have a petra okay
d3 is already a red flag
okay bishop goes back yeah these are
like more beginners
but white's white's not blundering
anything which is
okay bc
okay
um
no i think it's higher than a thousand
but not by much
i think it's higher than a thousand
but not by much or maybe not even higher
than a thousand i'm going to say 1100
this could also be like nine i could see
this being nine hundred
thirteen forty four yeah okay
yeah for thirteen hundred they did not
play very well
um i agree to the kilo there yeah maybe
you should have even gone higher
okay so first of all already a red flag
d5 here is crushing
[Music]
yeah i'm gonna say the same thing here
this is probably like 1200.
okay black actually played very well
here
b6 is impressive very consecutive play
by black
i'm i'm gonna say black is 1400 and
white is 1200
so i'm gonna guess 1300.
ooh 1538. yeah i keep underestimating a
little bit
but still still very decent
um
okay
[Laughter]
knight two three one zero
i mean usually people like where like
1700 play knight c3
11.99 not bad
okay
okay so knight c3 knight c6 we have
another four nights
whoa
castling along in that position jesus
christ
white somehow gets the attack
d3 somehow white's white started very
poorly but then
then actually played a lot better i'm
gonna say
let's say let's say
1600
yeah oh my god by five points oh
that's a good spot to stop wow okay
i mean that was not a hard hard guess
because it was just the right
neighborhood
but um that's like it doesn't get any
better than that
perfect score
my first perfect score
more elo gets her okay i'm down to do a
couple more
all right so
let's see
we've got okay bishop b5 is already a
pretty big red flag
where am i going i'm
i mean i'm going pretty soon i can stay
for another 15 minutes but probably he
should rate somebody else
okay this is really weird
this is trippy
this is very trippy
queen g4 knight d6
white's actually
white's attacking pretty nicely here
rook d6 knight f6
this is very hard to guess i mean this
could be
no this is definitely higher than 800
wow look at the staircase mate that's
pretty that's pretty impressive
now the only thing that concerns me is
this bishop b5 move that's a very weird
move
that's like a 1200 move but then
bishop h5 and then castling
i can see like a 1500 play like this i
think white was 1500
maybe black was i'm gonna say
let's see 13.50 average
1712 yeah i should have gone higher than
that
yeah no i i underestimated i mean bishop
b5 was weird so
yeah he pre-moved russell limo but still
that's a weird thing to pre-move
okay
okay black preparing some
crap there
okay they're not taking anything knight
takes d6
wait whoa
wall
that was like a weird botes gamba type
situation
again all of a sudden they're playing
well in the end game i don't get it
and black one by cluck
this could be literally anything i
mean i mean white saw that fork
let's say i'm going to say
1400.
yeah 14.45
um thank you guys it was a fun stream
sorry that i don't i'm not staying
longer but i gotta go i'll see you guys
see you guys later thank you for hanging
out and appreciate the support goodbye
everybody
[Music]
you